hello and welcome to this video playing
Tokai to walk in a Scandinavian defense
okay yeah I always play that line and I
think it's just better for white I think
here III don't know what a long night
before I mean just better for white it
means that white is slightly better not
by a mile I don't quite understand the
attractiveness for Blacky I mean why
would you play it but okay it's not
terrible or anything always feel like
white is just having a super easy time
again all the space and black is just
sitting there with no active plan
whatsoever especially considering that
you have not traded a single minor piece
which is really something that you
should should try yeah Queen d2 look do
you want something like that
I would like to play in the right moment
d5 which is probably not so easy to
manage just want to get out of this
opposition here maybe e5 is an idea for
Blanke that looks a bit odd
I mean okay can I do it can I do
something there okay I have B five and
ninety five but you were probably just
returned then to the eighth I mean yeah
McKim it was clear that he was wasn't
ending with a smooth and I am absolutely
not certain if it is any good I mean I
can play b5 and 95 and what happens
nonsense
his own deform enough to take it
actually which I did not really which
did not really register with me
you're not going to double you're not
going to double on the default and take
with the pawn right he is doing that
okay I mean I don't think it's terrible
actually it just looks very very
inconsistent in some way okay mmm yeah
should especially be five a move that
it's worth considering here yeah maybe I
probably need Ruby one so clearing
huh really unsure I need to speed up him
I was really unsure about taking on c6
if this is if this is helpful or not
okay I don't know know it I'm sorry
Bishop e5 the trade would be nice really
nice and yeah he will move it back in
probably three seven or something like
that to d8
no shouldn't blunder into f6
[Music]
we should have six Queen f4 was my idea
then that I didn't have on the radar
because it looks very nice for me got f3
next
Wow okay take Queen takes there was a
temple on the bishop which I did not I
can I could have still T done that yeah
well him I mean I'm in good shape now I
don't really I don't really mind if I'm
slightly imprecise and keep the time
situation in check
they have 693 not a problem and night
against this Bishop and ending it would
be a fantastic of course and veneering
that we really do
yeah 93 I wonder but I don't really
don't really want to go to the three
it's not a great square
Quinn's right is immediately winning so
cannot afford that
not yet certain how I'm going to I'm
going to convert it Knight f5 probably
doesn't do it okay now that's when me
let's do any now I get the 95 and that
you cannot survive that's not possible
I don't think hey maybe I'm wrong
[Music]
don't think he needed to give that yeah
it was the nets and ending that I don't
I don't quite believe you can hold water
okay so he played here with this
doubling on the deef already almost
blunted the default pond that was really
quite close yeah
okay Luke engine the engine suggestion
is funny a B 595 G for Bishop back age
for hooray yeah that's a kind of play
that you should think about is
particularly like in in classical chess
if you have time to consider instead a
weakening or I mean how he just killing
back and I mean killing is stronger but
it looks dangerous M the slope dangerous
I I really really didn't didn't register
that he's so much on d4 that I started
had to keep the pop even he I expected
rook takes of course and my intention
was to play Bishop c4 look back and then
d5 actually which the engine hates
others bishop before I move that I did
not see okay that's not good
yeah root cakes looks more logical and
if you know he doubled their I keep the
default open so then that wasn't
terrible at first I think this is still
kind of okay okay engine wants to go b5
yeah certainly it's possible I had this
this other idea and I think I'm more
comfortable now Queen d2 it's all all
engine choices we should be five looks
good back
small things and yeah this is now
getting really nice here with ya here I
could have done that already what I did
not see is that I can't actually take
now on c7 can I
I'm Bishop g5 oops oops that's not good
at the end just plays Bishop f4 and
keeps that pin in effect yeah definitely
yeah I'm gonna keep a bit big advantage
with with what I did but it's not wasn't
s convincing Oh Knight f6 ah that's cute
I didn't see that check check check
and you win the exchange and the game
that's very cute I mean I what I did I
could have found found that I think if I
have a bit more time because I was
actually thinking about this motif yeah
well with the check but of course he's
got King f8 and covers the Queen so that
is nonsense so as I kind of spotted that
there are those ideas with Knight f6 but
this is a really cute one
I came I mean I mean I wasn't really
hard pressed to look because I'm I knew
that doesn't ending I could have taken
c7 then the ending is just eternally
better and it's okay if you have that
little time to just make quick moves and
yeah continue to exert pressure I mean
here I think I should that should I'm
winning if not that would be a bit weird
actually
night these many kingi three and don't
quite get this yet are you just going to
h4 h5 ah okay it's impossible to prevent
really like here you do check and here
and again mmm yeah yeah something
something like that should be winning
even even g5 I think should be winning
it doesn't seem to be the best Wow it's
a drawn according to the engine
hard to believe but man not impossible
just okay so that means g5 is rubbish
how am i winning that Knight to f5 or
something boy I said some some super
song and play what don't quite yet
understand what the engine wants to do
like maybe this this this yeah okay that
makes a lot of sense keeping the
pressure then then you win that point
okay yeah a tough game
there was a chat suggestion during the
game of Bishop d3 in this position that
I didn't like because I think that even
after the simple capture and then
something like that that should be fine
that's a lot like Alekhine's defense in
some lines now the pieces I have those
at the space this is good but the pieces
here are not that great and if Black
gets quick enough on the e-file he will
probably be able to trade a lot yeah and
this this can be a square I don't like
to trade Bishop to Bishop him
okay guys thanks a lot for watching